Let's consider a
wheel that's rolling.
So our wheel is rolling
along a surface.
The wheel has radius r.
And I want to consider
the motion of a point P
on the rim of the wheel.
Now, I'll choose an
origin that's fixed.
And in fact, here we're going to
talk about the reference frame
A, which is fixed to the ground.
And I would like to
consider-- my problem is
to find both the position
of the point on the rim,
the velocity of the
point on the rim,
and the acceleration
of the point in the rim
as a function of time.
Now, the position vector is
given from my fixed origin
to where the point
on the rim is.
Now, this can be
quite complicated.
But what we're going to do is
consider a second reference
frame that is located at the
center of mass of the wheel.
So our second frame,
we'll take reference frame
and we'll call this
frame cm, is located,
is moving with the center
of mass of the wheel.
So in that reference
frame, we'll
denote this point
by vector r cm,
because we're in the
reference frame with respect
to the center of mass, and
we're talking about the point P.
Now, these vectors
are connected.
And we'll call
this vector capital
R. By our vector triangle,
capital R equals little rP--
that's the position vector.
And the fixed frame of the
ground is given by capital
R plus r cm P.
Now, as we've seen before
by differentiating,
the velocity of the
particle is given
by V plus V cm P. This one
is the velocity in frame
fixed to the ground.
This is the velocity
of the center of mass
with respect to ground frame.
And finally, V cm
P is the velocity
in the center of mass frame.
Now, in order to analyze
this law, what we'll now do
is focus on what
the motion looks
like if you're an observer
moving with the center of mass.
And that's how we'll
begin our analysis.